but uh you know like i you know i own a
house
i obviously own a condo i invest my
money i am smart with my finances
because
i've done really well in the porn
industry but it's
like a stepping stone to more
right like i want to set myself up
gotcha you feel me so would you say that
you've had more success with your
finances or in your relationships
finances
i am single as [ __ ] but oh my god so
i've been single for three years and i
swear to god the longer i've been on
dates yeah but the longer i stay single
you know how nice it is to come home and
not have to deal with nobody's [ __ ]
and set my like
you know what i mean like just there's
nobody to an extent yeah to an extent
but i can still want to find a man do
you not eventually i would love to
settle down but i've been there i've
lived with guys i've dated guys you know
i've had long-term relationships at this
point i'm after my bag i have a goal
and
that's it
you're after your bag what is that
meaning like i have a certain type of
goal that i want to reach whenever i
date i make less money
really yes because guys are distracting
me like like which is fine but what i'm
saying like when i'm single i definitely
always 100 make more money but you do
want to find a man
well yeah i don't want to be like a cat
lady when i'm 80. okay and by then i
hope i'm dead to be honest do you want
to have kids i don't want to live that i
don't want to have kids no kids i've i
haven't won i've i've just haven't
i have kids i have two south korean
pomeranians
okay they're my children they're
expensive you're one of those people
like yeah my dogs are my kids are those
people because there's some ladies
excuse me there's some ladies that
legitimately think that that that their
kids their dogs
came out of their vagina okay first but
that's not true listen listen sir i may
have not birthed them but i brought them
to my house gotcha and they live a very
very well life they have their own trust
they're good they're set up your dogs
have their own trust so let's say if i
die tomorrow in a car accident somebody
is going to get money to take care of
them
i need life insurance so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
[Music]